I’m here in uh Tonopah…and
I’m here in Tonopah, Nevada and we stayed last night at a fairly infamous motel
A place called the Clown Motel
and here it is
It’s a little bit hard to capture
with standard photos so
I thought I would try to use this 360 camera...
...what you can’t see right now is the old miner’s cemetery
just off to the right of me.
Each room comes supplied with clown portraits.
Catering to bikers, truckers and other long haul travelers
the Clown Motel is final port of call before another long stretch of unbroken desert.
The check-in room we are approaching has over 700 clowns in it
The entire office is covered in shelves and bookcases full of dolls, statues, and stuffed clowns.
A full sized clown sits in the corner.
It is a mirthful menagerie staring down at you from every angle.
Remarkably, there are not many stories, horror or otherwise about the Clown Motel
It is possible that this paucity of history is because is simply arose, fully formed
from the dark parts of the American subconscious...
Or it could be because so few have made it out alive…